[Music]
oh boy america time now for the most
unimpeachable man in our fine land mr
vladius and we got the video evidence to
prove it
uh thank you very much for that tony to
copel here a few stories we think you'll
be talking about today
a new video shows just how inspired
people
are by pro football star hayden hurst
the atlanta falcons tight end gave a
pair of emotional interviews last year
about his dark battle with depression
his truth touched people across the
nation
people like you speaking up is what we
need and it gives people like me
the strength i mean you're doing a
wonderful thing here honestly i can't
thank you enough for that
i i may be an eagles football fan but
i'll always be a haydenhurst fan thank
you
thank you from the bottom of my heart
thank you
i love this so much the falcons yeah the
falcons released the video
of people thanking hers for his impact
the 27 year old also opened
the haydenhurst family foundation to
help people
dealing with mental illness and to stop
the stigma
surrounding it uh we talked about this
on this show
yeah hour very important
i love that he's being applauded for
doing this yes yeah i also love that he
plays for the falcons and the one guy
had to be like look i love you but i'm
going to be an eagle eagles fan
but a haydenhurst fan evidently above
all powerful vlad
very much and we are too uh okay
incredible story here the coast guard
came to the rescue of three people stuck
on a deserted island
in the bahamas for more than a month the
cuban nationals say
they swam to angela key between key west
and cuba after their boat capsized one
woman
and two men were stuck there for 33 days
they say they survived by eating conch
and
rats yikes and building a makeshift
shelter gotta do what you gotta do
this video shows the coast guard
dropping off food
water and a communication radio to the
castaways down below
they had flagged down a pilot who
circled back to the island after
spotting their eye-catching signals for
help
including multi-colored flags the three
were airlifted to a hospital in key west
and were treated for fatigue dehydration
and other issues but they're okay so
could we eat rats
well i could not if i was starving yeah
33 days on an island there would be i'd
probably go this is the best i've ever
how about survival passing on that gene
pool
gotta survive okay uh all right so this
is one of the greatest stories ever
a virtual court hearing in west texas
produced a moment
that you might call i didn't write this
a meowsing
housing amazing i'm not my assistant
here she's trying to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
combination of the cat looking forlorn
and yeah
uh we talked to that lawyer his name is
ron ponton
unfiltered about that feline flub that
has gone viral watch
our nation needs a collective laugh
we've had a hard damn
year this past year and if they haven't
if they have that laugh at my experience
go have it i'm happy so during our
interview i couldn't help but have a
little fun with pont and here i am
that filter to use here we are as two
little kitty cats who do you think wore
it better
what was so great about this did he
laugh when he saw it he totally did
because i came on
this my zoom as a cat and he just burst
out laughing
and it was really really incredible so i
heard it was it was he was using his
secretary
yes and her 10 year old daughter had
been playing it and
left the cat filter i'm glad you added
that because i was a little suspicious
yeah about why he had a full
investigation now that happened he
couldn't really figure out how to turn
it on right apparently she couldn't
either when they came
right but other guys in the video
laughing though that's the other thing
the beauty of it was mr ponton's voice
was fabulous glad thanks so much we'll
be right back